many are going through a different
process to file and it may
cha and the change may be daunting
reporter madison kimbrough spoke with an
expert who shared some key information
she joins us live in the studio with
more tonight madison yes sasha between
social distancing
filing for unemployment and ppp loans
this year many people are going through
a much different process when it comes
to filing their taxes
so different that they don't know where
to start luckily the irs is forthcoming
with all the information that you need
tax season is upon us and with the
coronavirus taking center stage
our tax filings are proof that the
pandemic hit us hard
for instance for many taxpayers last
year was the first time they had to file
for unemployment
documentation is going to be very
different
for some taxpayers this is the first
time
they receive unemployment so they have
to wait for that
form and for taxpayers that are still
missing their stimulus checks
the irs will help them get that money on
their tax return
now that you have to do your taxes for
2020 there's going to be a
reconciliation
of all your stimulus money that you have
received and that
you were entitled to on your tax return
you are gonna tell the irs this is how
much money i got
from my first stimulus check and this is
how much money i got for my second
stimulus check
sales says your tax return will
calculate if there's any difference or
any outstanding balance regarding your
stimulus check
as for communication on documentation
that's going to be essential this tax
season
more so than ever before communication
especially with your previous employers
on the irs and if you change your
address
for any reason try to keep everybody
updated so you can receive those
documents
on time and you have all the
documentation ready
when you filed your taxes many tax
preparers are now virtual
due to the pandemic so it's important
that you have a secure way of
communicating with them there's a lot of
hacking and there's a lot of
identity theft going on if you are
someone who owns a small business and
benefited from the paycheck protection
program
as long as you use the loans on certain
business expenses like
payroll and rent you will not have to
pay back that borrowed money
however you still need to get your loan
forgiveness application approved by the
small business administration
before you're off the hook for the
amount you borrowed
and as for the irs free file program it
is available to those that make
less than seventy two thousand a year so
i'm going to show you right here we are
on the irs website
you're gonna hit this button right here
and it's gonna take you to the page that
you need to go to
to file that claim and the tax day is
april 15th as we all know but the irs
will start processing claims
as early as friday february 12th live in
the studio madison kimbrough 8 news now